Welcome back, before we say goodbye,
we wanna play a quick round of-
Drewth or dare?
(audience cheers)
And we have Cassandra Obouza.
Hi Cassandra, how are you?
Hey, I'm doing great.
How are you doing?
Great.
So today, I've got Drewth for the both of you.
Okay, okay, hit us.
So you know in this world of COVID-19,
and a lot of people are working from home.
How many days a week do you wear the same pajamas?
Because if I'm gonna be honest,
I wear my pajamas like three, four,
sometimes five days a week (laughs).
So yeah, how many days do you wear it?
Am I by myself with the three, four, five times (chuckles)?
So on days that I'm not going anywhere, for Christmas,
Wellie and I got each other the same pair of pajamas
in the same color and the same size.
True story, we didn't even know.
It turned out you were that couple.
Yeah, we were that couple.
It was on sale.
It's a cashmere little hoodie, pajama number.
And I would wear that every day of the week if I could.
Do you understand me?
Well also, you cannot wash cashmere,
that has to go out to the dry cleaner.
You gotta hand wash it.
That's my excuse.
But I would say really, probably three minimum, yeah.
It's old sweatpants for me
and I wear them out until they get holes in them.
I'm that guy.
So I don't know how many days in a row I wear them,
but I wear them until they have to get thrown away.
I work those clothes hard.
That's good though, no waste, that's good.
(audience claps)
Does that answer your question?
Oh, that was not a question.
Thank you so much.
Well, thank you, Cassandra.
Thank you for choosing to spend your time with us.
We make this show for you,
so take it with you.
(upbeat music)